the prime minister  there's Trust walking in alongside her  husband Hugh O'Leary Simon case cabinet  secretary also following on behind  thank you  the words of Liz truss our country has  grown and flourished under Her Majesty's  Reign Britain is the great country that  it is today because of her she ascended  the throne just after the second world  war she championed the development of  the Commonwealth we are now a modern  thriving Dynamic nation and through  thick and thin Liz trust said Queen  Elizabeth II provided us with the  stability and the strength that we  needed she was the very Spirit of Great  Britain and that spirit will endure  foreign  [Music]